[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
[Jubel]
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt's wieder ein richtig cooles "Murats 5 Minuten"
Ganz, ganz einfaches Rezept,
saumäßig schnell und ich glaube,
diesmal schaffen wir wirklich die 5 Minuten,
wenn wir natürlich das
doofe Gelaber wegnimmt von uns,
dann schafft ihr es auf jeden Fall.
Weil oftmals hat man Kinder.
Wir haben auch welche Kinder,
2 Stück,
ehm, und, ehm
hat keine Zeit -
Ne, vergiss es!
Man hat einfach keinen Bock was zu machen,
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen,
groß was zu machen.
Das Zeug haben wir immer zu Hause,
ganz schnell gemacht.
Und dazu habe ich meinen Assistenten da.
Ihr kennt ihn,
die Staatsanwaltschaft in Karlsruhe kennt ihn ebenfalls.
Darf ich ihn vorstellen:
Güni!
[Jubel]
So.
Nicht so fest. [Lacht]
Auf jeden Fall.
GÜNI: Mit Abschlag.
MURAT: Das ist kein Gewaltverbrechen,
das ist Güni, mein Freund.
Also Freund heißt rein platonisch.
GÜNI: Bisschen Abstand, bitte!
MURAT: Ja, Danke schön. Ja.
Auf jeden Fall, eh...
Entschuldigung!
So. Güni und ich machen ein ganz, ganz einfaches Rezept,
und zwar machen wir eine Lasagnesuppe.
Es ist 'ne coole Resteverwertung mit Resten.
[Stille]
[Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Ne, ich sag nichts.
MURAT: Ja. Okay.
GÜNI: Nein, nein.
MURAT: Eine ganz coole Geschichte eigentlich.
Die Zutaten ganz, ganz easy.
Wir haben hier Olivenöl,
30 g brauchen wir.
Das ist von den Hainen meiner Mutter,
von den Olivenhainen meiner tür...
... Mutter aus der Türkei.
Dann haben wir ungefähr,
haben wir hier Hackfleisch, 500 g.
Wir haben eine Zwiebel.
Wir haben zwei Knoblauchzehen.
Wir haben 50 g dreifach konzentriertes Tomatenmark.
Wir haben 500 g Gemüsebrühe.
Wir haben 800 g gehackte Tomaten aus der Dose.
Dann haben wir 400 g trübes Wasser.
Warum trüb?
Weil wir das...
damit die Dosen ausgewaschen haben.
Weil wir aus dem Schwabenland kommen
und nichts wegwerfen.
GÜNI: Nicht wie du.
MURAT: Ja genau. Ich, du nicht.
Und hier haben wir noch Gewürze,
und zwar Gewürze, wie z. B.
1/2 TL Pfeffer,
1/2 TL Salz,
1/2 TL Oregano
und 1 TL Paprikapulver.
Was wir auch haben, ist...
GÜNI: Berg...
MURAT: Ja, Bergbohnenkraut habe ich noch vergessen.
Ungefähr 1/2 TL Bergbohnenkraut.
So. Was wir auch haben, sind -
ihr habt vielleicht daheim irgendwo Lasagneblätter rumliegen.
250 g, eh, Lasagneblätter
oder es sind ungefähr, 14 Blätter sind es ungefähr,
wenn ihr sie von Barilla holt.
Ist keine Produktplatzierung,
nur mal so gesagt.
So.
Übrigens die besten Nudeln der Welt.
Ja. Wusstest du das?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Nein! War mir klar.
So. Auf jeden Fall,
wenn ihr mal alle Zutaten zusammenzählt,
kommt ihr auf ungefähr 10 Zutaten.
Deswegen ganz, ganz einfaches Rezept,
weil wenn es 10 Zutaten sind - du hast 10 Finger.
GÜNI: Kannst du bis 10 zählen?
MURAT: Ja, ich kann bis 10 zählen.
Und wenn es 10 Zutaten sind, ...
GÜNI: Mach mal!
MURAT: Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
Vier.
Fünf.
Sechs.
Sieben.
Hm?
Ehm...
GÜNI: Ja?
MURAT: Acht.
Neun.
Zehn.
So, bist du jetzt glücklich?
Ja?
GÜNI: Toll!
MURAT: Danke schön.
Auf jeden Fall 10 Zutaten.
Da kommt der Güni auch nicht durcheinander,
weil er kann dann... er kann dann zählen.
So.
Auf jeden Fall, eh, fangen wir...
GÜNI: Abstand!
MURAT: Ah, Entschuldigung! Entschuldigung! Ja.
Entschuldigung! Ja.
Abstand halten!
So.
Dann nehmen wir hier einfach den Gusseisentopf.
Der hat ungefähr 5,5 l Fassungsvermögen,
ist ein mittelgroßer Topf.
So.
Dann tun wir hier
Olivenöl rein.
GÜNI: Schuss.
MURAT: Einen Schuss.
Zack.
Schuss Olivenöl.
Es ist ein kaltgepresstes Olivenöl.
Habt bitte keine Angst beim Anbraten,
weil ich tu's nicht scharf anbraten, sondern nur anbraten.
Das heißt, Olivenöl ist sicher bis 180°C.
Da brauchst du keine Angst haben.
Olivenöl ist sehr, sehr gesund.
Das...
Weißt du das?
Woher weißt du, wo die ältesten Menschen Europas herkommen?
GÜNI: Ich glaube, Italien.
MURAT: Ja.
Und zwar, wirklich ungelogen, wirklich aus Norditalien.
Und Italiener brauchen richtig wirklich viel Olivenöl.
Hab ich schon mal erwähnt,
dass die 37 l Olivenöl pro Kopf verbrauchen
oder waren es 7... 28?
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht.
GÜNI: Was? Im Monat? [Doing]
MURAT: Ja. Ne!
[Güni lacht]
Im Jahr.
Auf jeden Fall pro Kopf.
[Güni lacht]
Auf jeden Fall,
wir in Deutschland verbrauchen nur 2 l Olivenöl,
weil wir immer Angst haben, dass
kaltgepresstes Olivenöl -
dass du es zum Anbraten nicht nehmen darfst.
Darfst du nehmen,
weil 180°C werde ich hier nicht machen.
GÜNI: Ja, halt auch die Schwaben nehmen es
auch nicht so gern, weil es so teuer ist, Olivenöl.
MURAT: Ja, aber...
GÜNI: Ist ja teurer wie anderes,
wie Rapsöl oder...
MURAT: Ja, aber Güni,
der Aufwand für Oliven,
einen Olivenbaum zu haben,
den zu pflücken,
das Öl zu pressen, ist ein viel, viel größerer
als Sonnenblumenöl.
GÜNI: Bist du früher,
hast du da auch in der Olivenhaine...
MURAT: Was?
GÜNI: ... Öl gepresst?
MURAT: Ich press dich auch gleich, ja?
[Güni lacht]
So. Auf jeden Fall
Folgendes:
Olivenöl reingemacht.
[Güni stimmt zu]
Den Topf erstmal auf mittlere Hitze,
das heißt, wir haben Stufe 1 bis 10,
wir sind jetzt schon auf 5.
Genau. Warten, bis das Olivenöl warm ist,
warm ist - so um die 100°C.
Nicht zum Dampfen bringen.
Dann ist es schon zu spät.
Dann nehmen wir hier einen Löffel.
Danke schön.
So.
Oah was!
Ich sag's dir,
den nächsten Jurassic Park-Film,
den drehen wir zwei.
GÜNI: Oah!
MURAT: Oah!
GÜNI: Du wärst der,
du wärst der Tyrannosaurus Rex
MURAT: Aha. Warum?
GÜNI: Weil du so kurze Arme hast. So.
MURAT: Ah.
[Güni macht Geräusche vom T-Rex]
[Murat lacht]
MURAT: Okay. Auf jeden Fall... So.
Olivenöl. Fleisch anbraten.
So.
So. Während ich hier das Fleisch anbrate,
hab ich ein super Gerät besorgt:
den Speed Twin 2600 Pro.
Genau. Warte kurz, Güni.
Knoblauch kannst du auch gleich mit reinmachen.
Viermal ziehen Güni.
Mit Ziehen kennst du dich ja aus.
Du lässt auch mal gern einen ziehen.
Viermal!
GÜNI: Wer hat denn vorhin?
MURAT: Ich soll nochmal sagen?
GÜNI: Moment! Wer hat vorhin... ?
MURAT: Ich hab gezogen.
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Und dann hast du... ?
MURAT: Nichts.
GÜNI: Einen abgezogen.
MURAT: Nein. [Lacht]
Viermal, genau. Zack. Zack.
Und nochmal. Komm, ...
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: ... zweimal.
GÜNI: Das waren schon viermal.
MURAT: Dann lass es. Komm! Mein Gott eh.
GÜNI: Warte.
Hänänän.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Hey, weißt du, was cool ist?
Das ist ein cooles Männerspielzeug, gell?
So wie an der Motorsäge: zack, zack!
[Motorsäge]
Fleisch schön anbraten,
bis es nicht mehr rot ist, sondern bräunlich.
GÜNI: Das kannst du schon reinmachen.
MURAT: Genau. Mach die Zwiebeln rein.
Guck mal, wie schnell das ein...
GÜNI: Mach mal deine komische Kralle.
MURAT: Okay, pass auf. Das kann man machen.
So. Zack.
Meine Frau würde jetzt einen Schaber nehmen,
aber wir möchten ja nicht so viel spülen,
weil wir wollen ja Wasser sparen.
Wir machen das mit den Händen.
So.
So. Danke schön.
GÜNI: Da ist noch was drin.
Dann spül's doch aus.
MURAT: Achso.
GÜNI: Mit Wasser.
MURAT: Genau. Güni! Mein Gott. Du lernst...
GÜNI: Ne, darf man nicht!
MURAT: Warum nicht?
GÜNI: Weil da noch kein Wasser rein darf.
MURAT: Ah, okay. Machen wir später, okay?
GÜNI: Doch der Schaber.
Ja genau.
MURAT: So.
Schön.
[Güni räuspert]
GÜNI: Kann man schon würzen?
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Alles rein, oder?
MURAT: Würze rein. Genau.
Hau sie rein, Güni.
GÜNI: Alles rein.
MURAT: Und würzen macht ihr wirklich
absolut nach dem Geschmack.
Ihr müsst, wenn ihr jetzt kein Bergbohnenkraut habt,
dann habt ihr es halt nicht.
Dann macht ihr was Anderes rein.
Was auch cool kommt,
du wirst es gar nicht glauben, Muskat ist gut.
GÜNI: Zwergbohnenkraut
MURAT: Na.
GÜNI: Tz.
[Güni lacht]
MURAT: Oah!
GÜNI: Was ist denn?
Hast du... ?
Bist du traurig?
MURAT: Ja.
Kennst du das?
Oah, ich sehe nichts mehr.
Weißt du, wie ich mir grad vorkomme?
Kennst du den Film "Bloodsport" noch?
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Kennst du noch?
Wo der Van Damme, wo er...
GÜNI: Kennst du, kennst du "Rollerball"?
MURAT: Nein.
GÜNI: Nein?
MURAT: "Rollerball" kenne ich nicht.
GÜNI: Oh, das musst du mal gucken.
MURAT: Okay.
Bei "Bloodsport" war es so,
wenn ihr den Film nicht kennt,
das ist ein alter Van Damme Film.
Der hat dann irgendwie so Pulver ins Gesicht bekommen,
hat nichts mehr gesehen,
hat aber dann trotzdem noch den Kampf gewonnen,
[Schlaggeräusche]
weil er,
weil er den Partner,
weil er den Gegner einfach
gerochen hat.
Ja.
GÜNI: Da hätte man bei dir auch kein Problem.
MURAT: Ja.
[Beide lachen]
So. Auf jeden Fall... Was machen wir als Nächstes Güni?
Tomatenmark.
GÜNI: Nein!
MURAT: Doch!
Warum nicht?
GÜNI: Noch nicht.
MURAT: Was als Nächstes?
Aber das ist doch mein Rezept.
Du darfst noch nicht wieder sprechen.
GÜNI: Achso. Okay Chef.
MURAT: Ja. So.
Dann machen wir Tomatenmark rein. Genau.
GÜNI: Nein, da ist ja noch,
da ist ja noch ein Haufen drin.
MURAT: Oh, natürlich. Tut mir leid, Güni.
Du hast recht.
So.
Dreifach konzentriert.
So. Tomatenmark reingemacht.
Güni, als Nächstes nehmen wir das Wasser,
Gemüsebrühe, 500 ml.
GÜNI: Tu du doch erstmal richtig anbraten.
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Halt! Halt!
Das kann man alles jetzt nehmen zum Ausspülen, ...
MURAT: Genau. Spül's aus!
GÜNI: ... die Zwiebeln.
Guck mal da.
Wir...
MURAT: Oah das ist richtig..., das ist richtig gut.
GÜNI: Ich sage ja, wir verwerten alles hier.
MURAT: Genau. Wir verwerten alles.
So.
Und Gemüsebrühe -
das hat meine Frau schon mal selber gemacht.
Wenn man Gemüsebrühe selber macht,
schaut einfach auf das Video
"Sally Gemüsebrühe selber machen".
Ihr könnt aber auch diese Gemüsebrühewürfel nehmen,
500 ml Wasser rein, Gemüsebrühewürfel rein,
1 bis 1,5 - kommt drauf an.
So.
Machen wir auch mit rein.
GÜNI: Es gibt Tomaten.
MURAT: Perfekt. Jetzt nehmen wir die Tomaten.
GÜNI: Nimm mal das da aus der...
MURAT: Oh.
GÜNI: Halt!
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Halt! Ich helf dir. Komm mal her!
Halt mal! Erstmal Wasser.
MURAT: Du tust mich grad echt überraschen.
Hast du einen Geistesblitz?
GÜNI: Ich bin...
MURAT: Normalerweise bist du nicht der...
GÜNI: Ne, ich bin heut nicht aggressiv.
MURAT: Bist weder der Hellste noch der Schnellste.
GÜNI: Du?
MURAT: Ja?
Ich bin schnell weg und schnell müde.
[Beide lachen]
So.
Cool.
Tomatenmark,
Entschuldigung,
Tomaten aus der Dose,
ist egal, ob ihr gestückelt nehmt oder am Stück nehmt,
es ist wirklich egal.
Und Tomaten aus der Dose sind meistens,
muss ich eins sagen,
sind meistens besser als ihr Ruf.
Auf jeden Fall kocht das jetzt richtig schön auf.
Das ist eine richtig coole Suppe nachher, wirklich!
So. Jetzt lassen wir das jetzt mal so richtig mal alles mal ziehen.
Kommst du wieder ins Spiel mit Ziehen.
Richtig ein bisschen ziehen,
so ungefähr 10 Minuten kurz köcheln lassen.
Und nach diesen 10 Minuten legen wir einfach
diese Platten drauf
und dann lassen wir es nochmal...
GÜNI: Nein, die werden reingebröselt.
MURAT: Ja. Ich meine... Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Wollte ich gerade machen.
GÜNI: Nein, du hast gesagt "drauflegen".
MURAT: Ich... warte, ich war gerade zum Weinen.
GÜNI: Oh.
MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall...
Wir lassen es mal 10 Minuten köcheln, alles ziehen,
die ganzen Gewürze müssen ins Fleisch einziehen.
Die ganzen Gewürze müssen sich verteilen.
GÜNI: Ja, was jetzt: einziehen oder verteilen?
MURAT: Ja, eh... tu mich nicht, eh...
stell mir nicht so viele Fragen!
[Güni lacht]
Ich hab nur so wenig Antworten.
So.
GÜNI: Okay.
MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall
kurz, wie gesagt, 10 Minuten ziehen lassen
und dann die Lasagneblätter reinbröseln,
richtig cool reinbröseln - hast du recht Güni -,
aufbrechen.
Und dann haben wir schon mal unsere...
GÜNI: Nicht aufbrechen.
MURAT: Was, Güni?
GÜNI: Zer-brechen!
MURAT: Zerbrechen.
Versuchst du mich gerade grammi-,
grammatikalisch zu verbessern die ganze... ?
[Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Du hast "grammi" ...
MURAT: Was hat nicht gepasst? Mein Syntax?
GÜNI: Was für ein?
MURAT: Weißt du, was die Präposition ist?
GÜNI: Das bist nicht du.
MURAT: Doch.
Jetzt hab ich mal 'ne Frage.
Du bist manchmal wirklich ein kleiner Klugscheißer.
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: So.
GÜNI: Zählt nicht.
MURAT: Doch.
MURAT: Sag mir mal, was ist Präsens?
GÜNI: Verb!
MURAT: Was?
Was ist das?
Können wir das aufnehmen?
Kann ich das wirklich... ? Ich will gar nicht -
Was ist es? Ein Verb?
So. Präsens ist
Gegenwart.
Ja.
Was ist...
Was ist das Gegenteil von Präsens?
Ist?
GÜNI: Präservativ.
MURAT: Okay.
[Beide lachen und Gelächter aus dem Hintergrund]
Wir hören noch...
GÜNI: Weißt du noch das Beispiel...
MURAT: Ich glaube,
GÜNI: ... besser bei dir.
MURAT: Ich glaube... [lacht]
GÜNI: Das sind ein paar...
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Oh mein Gott!
Okay. Eh, Güni, ich sage dir eins:
Bildungsfern...
GÜNI: Sei ruhig! Sei ruhig!
MURAT: Bildungsfernsehen werden wir nicht mehr.
Bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Wenn wir so weitermachen, werden wir auch nie
bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen...
GÜNI: Nein, ...
MURAT: ... landen.
GÜNI: ... du darfst nie Leschs Kosmos machen.
MURAT: [Lacht] Ja, Leschs Kosmus... Lesch...
GÜNI: Kosmos!
MURAT: Kosmos, genau.
Werden wir auch nie machen. So.
Auf jeden Fall - oah das riecht schon...
Mmh! Weißt du, wonach das riecht?
Das riecht nach Lasagne.
[Doing]
Ja, weil es auch eine Lasagnesuppe ist.
Aber richtig cool und auch voll schnell gemacht, gell?
Eigentlich wären wir theoretisch,
wenn wir nicht so doof labern würden,
wären wir eigentlich schon fertig.
GÜNI: Du.
MURAT: Ja, ich.
Wie?
Ja.
Während Güni jetzt an mir rumfummelt,
mach ich den Deckel jetzt einfach zu.
Genau.
Den Kochlöffel raus. Zack. Zack. Zack.
Übrigens ist es ein Backlöffel.
So. Einfach 10 Minuten ziehen lassen.
Hier war was Anderes drin.
Das ist ein anderes Video,
aber das seht ihr auch nochmal
später oder habt ihr vorher gesehen.
Jetzt haben wir es gerade mal ein bisschen köcheln lassen.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Lasagneblätter.
Ich mach einfach ein bisschen wenige. Zack.
Und jetzt einfach reinbröseln. Richtig? [Knackgeräusche]
Oh!
So.
GÜNI: Das habe ich mir gleich gedacht,
dass es so endet bei dir.
MURAT: So.
[Knackgeräusche]
Das macht auch Spaß, gell?
Das ist irgendwie Aggressionsbewältigung.
Weil ich habe mir gerade gedacht:
"Entweder mache ich Lasagneblätter kaputt
oder ich mache dich kaputt."
[Beide lachen]
Und ich hab gesagt, eigentlich, eigentlich wirklich
extrem easy.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich ein bisschen mehr Lust hat
und auch ein bisschen mehr Lasagneblätter,
kann man auch ein bisschen mehr Lasagneblätter reinmachen.
Von der Würze her, Güni?
GÜNI: Kräuter.
MURAT: Ich probiere mal ganz kurz die Würze.
GÜNI: Muss man abschmecken.
MURAT: Mmh!
GÜNI: Jeder, wie...
Der eine mag es schärfer, der andere nicht.
MURAT: Boah, das sind aber voll so harte Dinger drin.
Irgendwas Hartes ist drin.
Aaaah! Die Lasagneblätter.
Aaaah!
Okay. Also nicht probieren, wenn die Lasagne...
GÜNI: Du hast doch die Lasagneblätte gehabt eben.
MURAT: Boah, das schmeckt richtig lecker.
Richtig lecker.
Mmh!
Wow!
So.
Jetzt sind wir fertig.
Und zwar ist unsere Lasagnesuppe
fertig.
Güni und ich haben natürlich keine Kosten und Mühen gespart.
GÜNI: Gescheut!
MURAT: Und es ist...
MURAT: Was?
GÜNI: Gescheut!
[Doing]
Gescheut heißt das.
Keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut.
MURAT: Was habe ich gesagt?
GÜNI: Gespart.
MURAT: Achso.
[Güni lacht]
Gescheut. Danke für die, ehm...
GÜNI: Ja, ich weiß.
MURAT: Mein Gott, bist du ein toller...
GÜNI: Ja!
MURAT: ... Grammatiklehrer.
GÜNI: Ja?
MURAT: Ja.
So. Wir haben hier jemanden da,
der sich eigentlich mit der Materie auskennt.
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Ja, im Gegensatz zu dir,
und zwar der Rouven.
So. Darf ich begrüßen:
GÜNI: Rouven.
MURAT: Rouven.
Rouven ist Elektriker.
Ne! Er war...
GÜNI: Italiener!
MURAT: Italiener. Ah, stimmt ja!
[Jubel]
Rouven ist Elektriker und Italiener.
Der Rouven
- hinein einfach in die Mitte -
eh, Rouven...
GÜNI: Der ist ja noch größer wie ich.
MURAT: Also... also für einen Italiener
bist du echt riesengroß.
ROUVEN: Ja.
MURAT: Ja. Was stimmt nicht mit dir?
ROUVEN: Die besten Gene gekriegt.
MURAT: Ja?
ROUVEN: Ja.
MURAT: Die besten Gene gekriegt? Okay.
GÜNI: Du? Oh!
MURAT: Bei dir ist...
GÜNI: Oh.
MURAT: Du bist doch hier...
GÜNI: Armes Tiger Tatti Tatti.
[Murat lacht]
MURAT: Rouven! Rouven ist Italiener.
Auf jeden Fall... Was machst du beruflich?
ROUVEN: Ich bin Elektriker und Smart Home mach ich auch.
MURAT: Ja genau. Ah! Stimmt genau.
Er macht bei uns das Smart Home und er macht die Elektrik bei uns.
Auf jeden Fall - er hat die Türen jetzt alle so eingestellt,
dass wenn der Güni direkt vor der Tür kommt,
dass der weggeschossen wird.
Ja. Richtig? Danke Rouven. So.
Auf jeden Fall - Rouven, wir haben dir was Cooles gemacht
aus deiner italienischen Heimat, und zwar Lasagnesuppe.
Kennst du das?
ROUVEN: Was?
MURAT: Ja.
ROUVEN: Wie bitte?
[Güni lacht]
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Aus seiner italienischen Heimat.
MURAT: Habt ihr schon mal in Italien Lasagnesuppe...
[Güni und Rouven lachen]
Habt ihr noch nie...
Jetzt sagt ihr wieder, ihr wolltet...
GÜNI: Du kannst gehen. Du kannst...
MURAT: Ich sehe schon die Kommentare
GÜNI: Du kannst ihm erzählen, dass in Italien...
ROUVEN: Ja. Zu wenig Pasta, oder wie? Was ist da passiert?
MURAT: Es ist... es ist nichts passiert. Es ist wirklich...
GÜNI: Das ist eine echte Lasagne...
MURAT: Oah, ich sehe schon alle Italiener uns erzählen:
Welcher Italiener macht 'ne...
ROUVEN: Okay, lass uns probieren.
MURAT: Lass uns probieren. Aber pass auf, Rouven.
ROUVEN: Ja.
MURAT: Du musst wirklich die Wahrheit sagen,
auch wenn es nachher heißt, dass du nicht mehr wiederkommst...
ROUVEN: Ich sag immer die Wahrheit.
MURAT: ... werden wir dich nicht mehr rufen.
Jetzt probier mal hier. Lasagnesuppe. Sieht auch richtig toll aus.
Guck mal kurz rein, Josh.
ROUVEN: Ja.
MITARBEITER: Da muss noch Crème Fraîche drauf.
MURAT: Ah ja! Genau. Crème Fraîche. Genau.
Ja. So. Oh, ein Trick nach dem anderen.
Crème Fraîche. Wie heißt Crème Fraîche auf Italienisch?
Gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht [lacht].
ROUVEN: Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
GÜNI: Creme Fresco heißt das.
MURAT: Was heißt das?
GÜNI: Creme Fresco.
MURAT: Ja, du kriegst gleich eine auf die Fresco. So.
Auf jeden Fall hier Crème - Creme Fresco.
GÜNI: Aber das heißt doch so, oder?
MURAT: So Rouven, jetzt machen wir
ein bisschen Crème Fraîche drauf.
ROUVEN: Wahnsinn ey!
MURAT: Jetzt aber ganz ehrlich sein, Rouven. Okay?
ROUVEN: Ja.
MURAT: Wie es schmeckt.
Willst du eine Gabel oder einen Löffeln?
Egal!
MURAT UND ROUVEN: Ist ja 'ne Suppe!
MURAT: Ah natürlich, ist ja eine Suppe.
Wäre... wäre...
GÜNI: Hast du eine Lebensversicherung?
ROUVEN: Ich mache es euch zuliebe.
GÜNI: Du hast doch Kinder.
ROUVEN: Euch zuliebe.
MURAT: Aber Rouven, wenn es echt nicht schmeckt,
weißt du, dann...
Sonst machen's die Leute nach.
Wenn es nicht schmeckt, dann schmeckt es nicht.
Dann kriegst du auch noch Ärger. Kriegst keine Aufträge mehr
und dann musst du wieder zurück nach Italien.
[Gelächter]
So ist es.
ROUVEN: Also. Guten Appetit.
Mmh!
Also besser als ich gedacht habe.
Ich hätte euch saurer eingeschätzt.
MURAT: Ehrlich?
[Rouven stimmt zu]
Cool, gell? Vom Geruch her riecht's nach Sheba.
GÜNI: Katzenfutter?
ROUVEN: Was?
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Woher weißt du...
ROUVEN: Auf keinen Fall.
GÜNI: ... wie Sheba riecht?
MURAT: Frag nicht!
GÜNI: Hast du 'ne Katze?
ROUVEN: Nein, das ist nicht... es ist nicht schlecht. Es ist...
MURAT: Gell?
ROUVEN: ... was Anderes.
MURAT: Rouven, und wir haben es ungelogen...
ROUVEN: Sieht so aus, wie wenn ich einfach
für meine Kinder klein schneide.
Dann ist es eine Lasagnesuppe.
Mmh!
MURAT: Bist du... Seid ihr Italiener eigentlich sauer
auf uns Deutsche, wenn...
ROUVEN: Nein.
MURAT: Wieso auf Deutsche? Auf den Deutschen.
ROUVEN: Ich glaube, die Suppe hättet ihr
ein bisschen länger kochen lassen müssen.
MURAT: Ehrlich?
ROUVEN: Ja.
MURAT: Mein Gott, jetzt übertreib. Tu nicht so.
Du bist Elektriker. Jetzt tust du grad so, als wärst du der Feinschmecker.
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Güni, sollen wir ihm Aua machen?
GÜNI: Kannst du...
ROUVEN: Ah was, es ist gut geworden.
MURAT: Ja?
ROUVEN: Mmh!
GÜNI: Klein...
ROUVEN: Deutsch... deutsch-türkische Interpretation...
GÜNI: Lasagne.
ROUVEN: ... Interpretation einer italienischen Lasagne.
MURAT: Ich find's voll lecker. Ganz ehrlich, ich mag das voll.
Vor allem, Rouven - es ist echt 'ne Resteverwertung,
ging saumäßig schnell
und genauso viele Zutaten...
ROUVEN: Ach deswegen...
MURAT: ... wie Güni Finger hat.
ROUVEN: ... Resteverwertung
Also...
MURAT: Mmh!
ROUVEN: Ich esse es dann mal da hinten.
MURAT: Ehrlich? Ja?
[Rouven stimmt zu]
Okay.
ROUVEN: Euch lasse ich dann weitermachen.
MURAT: Danke schön. Ja. Wir kommen gleich.
Ich zeig dir dann gleich,
wie das mit dem Elektroschrank funktioniert.
ROUVEN: Okay.
GÜNI: Ich geh mit. Warte mal!
MURAT: Nein, nein! Bleib du mal kurz da.
Bleib du mal kurz da.
[Doing] Du Dummbeutel. Du kannst doch keinen Italiener rufen,
wenn wir Nudeln machen.
GÜNI: Ah ja.
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
[Murat widerspricht]
MURAT: Man sieht's. Musst deinen Bauch weggürteln.
GÜNI: Was hast denn du heut an?
MURAT: Aha.
Also richtig cool. Ihr habt gesehen, es hat funktioniert.
Den Italiener haben wir schön manipuliert.
[Güni lacht]
hat ihm geschmeckt.
Gut, gell?
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Mmh!
Hey, die schmecken wirklich gut. Ohne Spaß, ja.
Die schmecken wirklich gut. Ohne Spaß. Macht das echt nach.
Jetzt tun wir noch kurz die Suppe noch absieben
für die Veganer, dass sie nicht merken, dass Fleisch drin ist.
GÜNI: Das ist alles Tofu.
MURAT: Tofu, genau. Alles klar.
Tschüss. Macht's gut. Macht's besser.
Und abonniert uns,
obwohl, ist nicht unser Kanal. Macht was ihr wollt.
[Güni lacht]
Tschüss.
[Musik]